let's do this marines it's no secret
that the call of duty modern warfare
series
loves to reuse their maps and
environments for more than 10 years
we've seen maps reused
recycled remastered and put into other
game modes entirely
let's take a look back at some of these
modern warfare maps that continue to
live on
up first on our list is crash 2007's
call of duty 4 modern warfare
introduced this multiplayer map that
lightly mimics the mission
shock and awe most would agree that
overall it's a really good map
there are tight corners high sight lines
good points for domination
and even the infamous alley on the side
that's always busy
right in the center of it all is the
crash it was reintroduced back into
multiplayer for modern warfare 2
and during the holiday season a special
version of christmas crash was released
this is a special nighttime variant of
the map that takes place during
christmas
in this mode when you're killed instead
of falling to the ground like normal
you explode into a pile of presents and
when you call in an airstrike
santa claus himself makes the delivery
even when this map was re-released in
2019's modern warfare it kept things
faithful to the original source
material with some small exceptions
being this courtyard
and the back area where your team spawns
everything else is here
now the crash helicopter contains the
chem bio weapons that were the threat of
both the campaign
as well as war zone storyline pretty
cool
next up we have kind of a fun one that's
more of an easter egg than anything
within the euphrates bridge map lies
another classic modern warfare map
called invasion
by using spectator mode you can clip to
the left of the bridge to find the
invasion map's outline
it's not fully textured but the
groundwork is all here
this was originally a multiplayer map in
modern warfare 2
based off the mission team player do you
see it yet
remember this little area that was
always filled with campers and people
chucking grenades
or how about back here people used to
love to camp this dome area
it's weird how even just this outline
can bring back so many memories
if you've ever played modern warfare 2's
multiplayer you know what i'm talking
about
next up is the infamous map rust rust
was originally used at the end of the
modern warfare 2 campaign when you fight
off shepard
i hate this scene don't make me look ah
that's better
after that infinity ward broke it out
right away as a multiplayer map
since then it's been re-released in call
of duty mobile and more recently in
2019's modern warfare
being such a small map not much has
changed the structure in the center got
a little taller
and everything else looks a little more
polished but that's to be expected
rust was also an easter egg in call of
duty advanced warfare's map
compound again using spectator mode if
you go outside of the boundaries of the
map you can find a structure that looks
just like rust
only made of shipment crates
next up on our list is scrapyard today
we may know this area as a small section
of the war zone map
verdansk and it's even been reintroduced
as its own multiplayer map
but it originally debuted in 2009's call
of duty modern warfare 2.
most of the map has remained the same
with some exceptions being
where the truck on fire is and the room
on the right has also expanded quite a
bit
with more cover and more ways in and out
different still is the verdance version
which now has a helipad on the spawn
side
did you know that a real-life version of
this map was made and gamespot was
invited to use the grounds for a
paintball match
vacant is another map that got its start
in call of duty 4
modern warfare from 2007 since then it's
been re-released into modern warfare 2
modern warfare remastered and currently
in 2019's modern warfare
it's also another small part of
warzone's map for dansk
taken from the missions all gillied up
and one shot one kill
vacant is a large single story office
building that was
modified into a multiplayer map upon
release the biggest changes in the
latest version
are the new buildings on the back of the
map that you can access through doors
the ground war and war zone version also
introduce
roof combat there's now also the
infamous war zone overpass here that
wasn't in the originals
how many times have you accidentally
dropped care packages back here just me
as the dlc pack for call of duty 4
modern warfare
we got the map broadcast for the first
time based on the single player mission
charlie don't surf
you may know broadcast as tv station
nowadays
and it's remained the same for the most
part the biggest changes here are the
surroundings of the map
and the rebranding of the tv station
itself seeing this teased in that
warzone trailer was pretty exciting
even though i'm happy to see it return i
don't always land there because it's
such a hot drop
what about you really quick i have to
throw in shipment
i almost didn't include this because of
the seven titles it's been in
only three of them are from the modern
warfare series but what is there to say
it's shipment you either love it or you
hate it
last up are the gulag showers this map
has only appeared in two games but has
been utilized in a lot of cool ways
already
the first time we see it we're rescuing
captain price aka prisoner 627
and bust out through the ceiling after
that it was reintroduced into modern
warfare in 2019
as the 2v2 map a small area in the
prison of her dansk
and of course using it when you lose in
warzone
while it's not exactly the same gulag in
each iteration it's cool to see that the
rope you use to escape with
still hangs above memories you know
and those are only some of the maps that
have been reused in the modern warfare
series
which ones you want to see come back let
me know in the comments
i personally want to see favela i also
remember that a lot of people love
dome you know what any map for modern
warfare 2 is fair game for me
thanks for watching i'll see you next
[Music]
time
[Music]
you